to move from one activity in this case
the main activity in our sunshine app to
another here the detail activity you
call startactivity but note that when
using the start activity method rather
than specifying the class name of the
activity to start directly that class
name is packaged explicitly within an
intent the basic premise is simple
whenever you need your app components to
communicate with each other or the
system you use intense to identify the
target destination starting activities
within your app is the simplest example
with your intent explicitly indicating
the target using the context and a class
name of the activity intents that use
the name of the component you're
targeting directly unknown as explicit
intents